hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast by dr. John I Freddie I'm dr.
Jared Snyder creative marketing manager
at Archer DX and I'll be your moderator
today here's how this presentation works
we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen will try
to get to everyone but if we run out of
time we'll make sure to follow up with
you by e-mail you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand of your slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button in your
lower left will monitor both now let me
tell you a little bit about dr. I afraid
II here it is md PhD from state
university of new york at stony brook
school of medicine and went on to
brigham and women's hospital for his
residency and fellowship he's currently
the medical director of the center for
the integrated diagnostics at
Massachusetts General Hospital John is
an innovator who identifies problems
with the status quo and works to solve
them as a molecular pathologist he
recognized shortcomings with the current
methods of mutation detection and so
over the last seven or eight years
Hina's colleagues have developed
technologies that enable large-scale
molecular molecular detection and to get
more to get more information from less
input material in a shorter amount of
time and with that I'll turn the time
over to dr. Riya Brady
ok Thank You Jared welcome everyone I
appreciate you guys signing on and
listening to this presentation I'm I'm
going to cover today some technology
developed in our laboratory here by
largely by two very talented scientists
dr. lonely and dr. zhang li zhang I get
the privilege of presenting but they did
a lot of the presentation and I just
want to give them some upfront credit
the technology we developed called
anchored multiplex pcr I sure I'm sure
most of you have heard about it if you
been looking at the archer website and
some of our publications we really
developed this early on as a method to
to move a lot of our fusion detection
analysis that we were using either fish
or IHC into the next-gen sequencing
world to get more cost-effective and
higher throughput so the ebb technology
really was a fusion based technology but
we've begun to mine it and improve it
and move it into other areas like snv
detection C&V detection and RNA
expression so let's not going to tell
you about today it's obviously NGS in
cancer analysis is a very very big field
we have about one hour to to go through
the material and so this is not going to
be a comprehensive overview of next-gen
sequencing I'm going to give you a
little bit of clinical background and
then really focus in on the amp
technology obviously a very our team is
bias on it we've developed the
technology we think there's a lot of
advantages I will touch on where it
compares to other techniques but it's
not going to be an exhaustive review of
other techniques which obviously have
have their place and have shown great
promise in the area of tumor genotyping
so outline practical challenges in
clinical genotyping just a couple of
slides just to put everyone on the same
page about clinical genotyping then
we're going to talk specifically for
most of the talk about amp technology
fusion s and V scene
the RNA expression and then clinical set
a little bit of clinical scenarios to
show you where we're applying it how
we're playing the technology at Mass
General Hospital obviously that's unique
to our own so before I start I just
wanted to give a little bit of a
conflict of interest disclosure the talk
is sponsored by Archer DX of which I
along with long song Lee and Jason Myers
were founders I continue to be an essay
be member and an equity holder and
Archer with that said I do want to
emphasize that today's talk is my own
content the data i'm showing you is
based on the mgh amp research i'm not
really going to be talking about Archer
kits or archer specific tools today for
those please follow up with Jared and
the archer team after the talk was not
approved by Archer DX so it's my own
content and so that's probably good or
bad if you were wanting to get more
specifics on the archer products I'm not
going to talk a lot about those
specifically on the other hand I would
add that we are obviously in close
contact with the archer DX team and a
lot of the tools that we've developed I
think in parallel they've they've moved
to commercialize so a lot of the things
that I'll be talking about i think will
be very applicable to any commercial
development and an interest in your
particular lab i'm bringing on the
technology ok so with those conflicts
disclosed i'm going to i'm going to as i
said give it a little bit of background
for a couple of slides just to put us
all on the same the same page most of my
interest in cancer genotyping started or
really accelerated around the
development of the drug crizotinib i run
the molecular diagnostics group at Mass
General Hospital and we we had been
quite quite busy over the years give me
one second I have a little pen here that
I'm going to see if I can use there we
go so we started early on as in the
development of croissant I've actually
before curzon impose was an open
clinical trial we were involved in
clinical pathology
analysis of alka positive cases dr.
Manos boob from Japan first described
this in 2007 we started screening on
these meralco fusions in lung cancer
just a few months after that paper was
published and we use fish we did we did
many many fish tests in fact became the
central lab for the phase one trial of
croissant nib and and got to play i
would say an integral role at least
early on on the development of companion
diagnostics in that space so we learned
a lot about companion diagnostics and
how report it is even for relatively
rare genotype to to uncover actionable
targetable mutation so happy to talk
offline with anyone about our experience
there I would say the most exciting
thing and the kind of lessons we learned
about crows i nip is if you do it right
if you have a good target and you have a
good drug you can move things along
quite quickly so dr. Manos group as you
know discovered you know for elk in 2007
and then accelerator pool krizan it was
obtained in 2011 about as fast as you
can go from what is a new drug and a new
indication to some fda approval so a lot
of what we've done afterwards is trying
to match this this rate and that's this
is a hard rate to keep up with but i
think something everyone would feel
probably a lot of a lot of you on this
call or are excited about in your
particular tumor type regulatory
challenges for those of you who don't
spend your time thinking about clinical
genotyping i'd like to give a couple of
slides to put us all on the same page
there's a number of entities that
control what we do at least in the
United States the FDA wants to know does
your device work obviously genotyping is
considered a device so they want to know
what clinical and technical validity CMS
is important should we get paid is their
clinical utility to what we're doing I
think this is our major hurdle for our
field of next-gen sequencing or clinical
genotyping the AMA provides codes will
talk about that in a second and then
Clea many of you probably have heard
about clear they don't run clear labs
Clea is not asking does the
device work necessarily the same way the
FDA does the Clea Clea regulations
really want to ask does the lab how to
know how to use the device do you have
the proper of quality assurance and
quality control so any recent
developments in fact they've been a lot
of recent developments around the FDA in
the FDA regulation of tests for labs
like ours academic labs there's been a
lot of a lot of interest and publication
of draft guidelines around the
regulation of lanthanum tests my lab
developed test that means tests that are
not FDA approved and in the cancer NGS
space I could ask the question to
everyone on the team on the ulna call
how many fda-approved Cancer NGS tests
are there right now and the answer is
easy there are there aren't any panel
test yet yet approved so the space we're
working in for now obviously some of the
big players including Lumina life Archer
kyochon are going to be very interested
and are very interested in proceeding
down the road of getting FDA approval
and that that will see in a few years
CMS as we talked about is a big question
should we get paid and can we get paid i
would say i'm also happy to talk to
anyone offline about this we spend a lot
of time right now talking to payers
whether private or or public the
medicare/medicaid to see can we come up
with with reasonable payment schedules
for for NGS the AMA has published three
coats for NGS they've won 4458 1450 and
81 455 in the US just this year which it
provides us the ability to to build but
it is not yet I think reached its full
potential and that we really don't have
payment payment rules and guidelines
published from each of the payers so we
still have some work to do so that's
currently where we stand I'm going to
come back to this timeline so I just for
one one thing you'd like to talk about
Elle DTS and the importance of lab
develop tests and and and progress in
the area of molecular diagnostics in my
opinion is the early law
chove rld tlk sa that allowed the rapid
approval of krizan of nail appt the
rapid progress of krizan and we wouldn't
have been able to launch that test as a
clinical test if it wasn't for the
ability to launch LD teas and in fact i
think the approval pros on it would have
been delayed at least two years if we
had not been allowed or the regulations
surrounding l DTS have been more
stringent at the time so the next slide
is an important slide for those who you
run labs many of you are well aware of
these terms but when we start talking
about an NGS platform and why we
developed amp you can look at some of
these considerations for clinical tests
we needed to work from our high def FB
material we need analytical sensitivity
especially pressing these down to five
percent or lower our clinicians put a
lot of pressure on us to get less than a
two-week turnaround time with NGS you
know it can be a challenge to get the
library construction bioinformatics and
reporting out within two weeks and so
those those are the major considerations
why we started looking at developing our
own technology or especially around
fusion detection actionable targets this
is an area of much negotiation much the
heartache i would say everyone has their
own list of actionable targets i'm not
going to spend too much time other than
our philosophy is we should have you
should be as comprehensive as we think
we need to be where everything on that
panel is actionable so there's there's a
happy medium between the number of
targets the amount of sequencing some
someone I think should do and be the
cost for doing that and so the happy
medium there is is picking picking
highly actual targets and this is not
really talked about clinical utility and
sustainability however the elephant in
the room I think for any talk like this
is nothing that we're talking about is
sustainable unless we have some some
clinical utility proof we're involved in
the NCI match trial which is which is
one of those type approaches at large
multi multi center actually multiple
cooperative group NIH funded study to do
to do such a thing and we're excited
about something we're excited about
trials like that but i would say we're
still we're still a few years away from
being able to show full full proof
evidence of clinical utility for
next-gen sequencing 2008 we launched
snapshot original genotyping essays a
hotspot mutation detection sa it served
us very well if you look at the gene
lists in the mutation they're really as
almost not almost all but many of the
important recurrent targetable genetic
alterations and it it still is a it's a
quite powerful assay that can be done
cheaply and quickly so in order to move
on we really to the next technology we
really need something that would compete
favorably with something that could be
done very cheaply and and quickly and so
that's why we started developing the
in-house and technology wrong hands on
wounded profiling in the snapshot era
this is lung adenocarcinoma one thing
that should pop out right away is
there's no mutations that we would found
in this type of panel about forty
percent and to us that was that was
showing that we're not helping as many
patients as we could have so we
obviously had to move to NGS and then
tumor suppressors like p53 when you look
at a hotspot mutation assay you just
don't get good coverage of tumor
suppressors because you are looking at
hot spots so for those two reasons we
moved on to NGS and I won't belabor
believe it be later that discussion
clinical utility I did mention this is
my last intro slide clinical utility
there's not been a lot of papers out
there showing the usefulness of next-gen
sequencing or broad genotyping for that
matter this is a paper from 2012 from
the MD Anderson group and I thought it
was you know it was not it was not a
randomized control trial but it was a
very interesting analysis of their phase
1 clinical trial data where they
genotype many many patients using a
similar SI as as our original snapshot
and show the response rate is much
higher in patients who are genotype and
go into a genotypes directed trial than
other phase 1 patients and don't and so
that type of data is out is out there
and we're beginning to see to see more
event and it's going to be very
important for payers okay so that's the
end of the introduction let's let's move
into NGS proper what are we doing at mgh
in 2015 right now if just to let you
know how
view it and what we're most interested
in doing we prefer medium sized flexible
panels the need I feel I think our team
all fields is to balance sequence costs
and comprehensive mystic and action
ability is important and for that reason
we've we're currently working on 55
panels solid tumor DNA for s and V snv's
in dose and CMV solitude infusion Sakura
fusion hematologic tumor DNA and
separate heating fusion and by
separating them out into different
panels you accomplish a few things
they're less genes / panel and you can
run more samples / / run pricey or my
seek or PM whatever using and obviously
keep costs at a minimum so to us this
balance is those two things of cost and
comprehensiveness the list may look
similar to what Archer DX provides and I
would say we've we've worked together
with the team there that we're very
close with to look at the gene lists and
make sure the content is is somewhat in
so some of the things i'll be talking
about well not exactly Archer kits will
be very similar to what you would find
from an archer offering the technology i
have a couple of slides describing the
the technology i think this is very
important to go into the details of why
amp is is very interesting zonely and
mom worked very hard to to develop this
it ends up being i think a quite a
simple approach and i think quite
elegant in its simplicity we're talking
to start with we'll talk about
translocations but the same the same
workflow this the same primer design
basically can be used for genomic DNA
there's really there's really no
difference other than your starting
material whether you start with double
strand cdna which is how we start with
our RNA sequencing or translocation
detection followed by and repair and a
tailing and then using these adapters
there why adapters hemi functional why
adapters where only one of the wise is
functional then gets ligated so both
sides of your library this is a random
library of double strand cdna gets your
deck adapters ligated so it's on both
sides of your fragment
and then you do two rounds of PCR wear
one of your primers is with within the
adapter tail and the other is a chain
specific primer where your Geno region
of interest is is just upstream of your
GSP one a lot of work that long as I'm
we did show that doing two rounds of PCR
was very very important to get high
level height on target rates and so
using the GSP to a second round of PCR
gives you over ninety percent on target
rate and so the essay as you can see
it's largely a pcr-based assay but it
has a couple of interesting components
which is this upfront random ligation
event so it has a little bit of hyper
capture random end type sequencing we'll
talk about combined with some of the
advantages of PCR which is it works
quite well with low input material down
to five to ten nanograms of input
material if you were to use genomic DNA
instead of having randomly produced
double strand cdna you would have shared
we would sheer double strand genomic DNA
and I would go into the into the into
the library I'm just going to give you a
brief introduction in this slide we'll
go into more detail about what the
sequencing itself looks like there's
some real advantages to the amp
technology it has a very unique
appearance when you look at a sequencing
pilot whole genome sequence hybrid
capture how's this Gaussian distribution
of reads where your capture probe would
be in the middle and you're capturing
different pregnant lengths around that
area of capture and you have multiple
stores and stop sites and those can be
very useful from a variety of reasons
quality control and looking at the
diversity of your library very difficult
to analyze diversity with pcr-based
amplicon based sequencing so many of the
clinical application platforms for
cancer where you need to go down to very
low levels of input material use
pcr-based primers where you get
identical start and stop sites it's very
difficult to assess complexity of
libraries when all of your reads don't
stop at the same spot for the amp
technology we have actually two primers
for each target
random ends because of your ligation of
your adapters is random on either one of
your ends and then we actually come with
a primer on the plus strand and apply a
primer in the minus strand and so that
actually gives you two different
distinct we pile ups that you contract
for each particular target and since you
have random ends for those reads you can
actually track a number of things you
can do error correction using molecular
indexing standard deduplication
techniques work just fine as well and
you can assess the diversity of your
library which is incredibly important
for low input FFP materials that will
talk about so I'm going to talk about
two things on this slide then I think
our advantage that we've tried to
incorporate into the technology cambrian
can be incorporated obviously into other
sequencing technologies I'm not saying
it's unique but we've tried hard to make
use of molecular indexing and by
template sequencing to reduce the false
positive rate so if we remember you have
these two Y adapters on your fragment
here so let's say this is the genomic
DNA fragment this dotted box is an exxon
of interest we actually have a set of
plus primers and a set of minus primers
and so these two can behave together
behaved very well together in the same
tube and allow us to generate two sets
let's say overlapping sets of library
fragments off the plus primer you can
see the anchored side is this side has a
flat end and then they're staggered
start sites on the on the opposite end
as you extend randomly to these two
where the sharing sites on we have these
ends on a in the adapter which are our
molecular indexing and allow us to buy
automatically group identical original
template molecules if that makes sense
and we'll talk about why that's
important in a second so for the plus
strand primer we actually get a set of
reeds I'm not showing here but you have
both forward and reverse coverage on a
sequencing read and then the minus
primer you have the opposite so you have
anchored side here and then stagger saj
there the minus strand you have forward
and reverse as well the error correction
comes in is it's very interesting as you
can separate the plus and minus you can
actually correct for thing
like seem to t mutations that are common
in ffp tissue so in this case I'm
showing a CDT mutation here only on the
plus strand but not on the main string
so that off the bat tells you right away
that there's an artifact here and the
CDT would only be happening the
oxidative deamination would only be
happening on one of the two strands
because you'd have a G on the other
string so you'd only see a mutation of
one but not the other and that allows us
to eliminate a number of the CDT
mutations that are quite challenging and
FFP material there's another aspect here
which is the molecular barcoding
molecular indexing or a standard
deduplication that is really important
so if you look at these reads right here
these top four I've actually designed on
purpose to have the exact same length
let's say these were the original same
template molecule they share the same
the same molecular index exactly index
and buyer from adequately they can be
grouped and if we have a team you tation
in a subset of those roots not all of
them not a consensus reads we would rule
that out as there's a false positive so
the molecular indexing and deduplication
abilities allow us to make these bins
that we can do intra bin correction that
lets us get rid of these false positives
and then the separate plus and minus
strand by template sequencing allowance
to do that a real mutation would be
present as shown here as am posting both
the plus and minus strand and again a
real mutation if it was present within
this particular original template
molecule would be present within all the
identical pcr duplicates right so you
can see the would see all for having a
devil so I would say we're just
beginning to really optimize how to
utilize this type of error correction
and mine mine this kind of data so we're
excited about it and we think the the
ability to work with low input materials
and gain some insight into into the
error rate is really important so almost
all the essays we do this was designed
on purpose by long ends only you
utilizes FFP material and we extract
total nucleic acids so we simultaneously
extract RNA in DNA into a single tube
and that can be utilized for all of our
downstream applications which we
currently have this is these are actual
screenshots of the
data that we have using amp for RNA
expression this is a 50 gene pool file
for RNA expression RNA fusions showing a
CD 74 nrg1 fusion DNA copy number
assessment which is relatively
straightforward as well as snv's and
inane tales so single starting material
we can get almost everything we want and
it's going to done out of low input
material so we're pretty excited let's
talk for a few minutes about the
challenges around all of these different
these different assays RNA expression
what are the challenges as everyone
knows thats dundas over the years
normalization of data is not
straightforward for NGS based especially
targeted RNA expression balancing a
primers we'll talk about is is really
important there's major challenges
around tissue-specific expression
especially in the diagnostic arena amp
offers several advantages the design is
easy you have the ability excuse me to
boost primers when you need to and all
this can be done relatively easy and in
a customizable way that's fast or any
fusions where the challenges there's a
lot of challenges around bioinformatics
of calling fusions mapping mapping to to
basically split reads and and making
sure that you can you can find both
partners off target effects the the
actual mapping of sequences can give you
off target effects that are dependent on
the expression level of an individual
target so you may see an off-target
effect only a tie in its sample that's
high-level expression of a particular
RNA and then we'll talk for for a slider
to bail limit of detection testing which
is really challenging in the clinical
and clinical trial arena the advantages
of app you need only want primary easy
design DNA copy number challenges
normalization of data low copy number
cases running a new challenge the
advantages of a molecular barcoding SN
VN in dells challenges mutations under
primer since it's it's somewhat of an a
primer base pcr-based sa we still have
some of the issues around mutations
under primers and where for the
bi-directional coverage allows us to get
around that the data format of app is
unique and it's taken us some
bioinformatics work some of the standard
platforms out there for mutation calling
are not optimized frame and type data so
we've had to work on that the advantage
event again or staggered start site
error correction bi-directional college
let's talk for a few minutes about
lonely put materials and I think this is
a very important as you compare
something like amp which which will give
you good data at 5 nanograms to an
amplicon based a pure amplicon based
assay that has neither molecular
indexing incorporated or the ability to
assess the ability to assess complexity
so if you if you take a sample and you
put into this is an ant based dnas a
showing we'd coverage over an egfr exon
from 200 nanograms to 5 nanograms what
do you see well up to 200 an event you
see an even distribution of we'd start
and stop sites and so that shows you a
very high quality library Wells down at
5 nanograms you may have a lot of reads
you may have let's say ten thousand
reads up here at two hundred and against
you can still have ten thousand reads
down here are you beginning to see this
very blocky read pile up where these
blocks represent large numbers of
identical weeds that have been PCR over
and over and to give you this kind of
step function so when we see this
visually we know this is a
low-complexity sample versus this smooth
distribution is a beautiful high
complexity example why does that matter
that matters because while you have ten
thousand reads down here you actually
probably only have ten or fifteen unique
reads and so if you're quoting your
sensitivity based on a validation run
gun at two hundred nanograms sample
where you can detect one in 100 or three
and 100 Newton reads here that
sensitivity does not relate is really
not relevant to a sample down here 5
nanograms we only had 20 Ruiz to begin
with so you're the best you could ever
do is one in 20 and if you'd like three
reads your best sensitivity ever would
be three and twenty weeks so you have a
much lower sensitivity on here something
you really can't tell from standard
amplicon sequencing we see this also not
just in low input but in poorly
preserved samples older samples and so
getting an idea of the complexity
library is incredibly important in the
clinic this is giving you another idea
this is a read pile up over 4x
in the cave as Jean this is data is only
it they had provided which is showing
you in in turquoise the raw data
coverage that is the raw reads the
non-consolidated non not using the
molecular indexing to consolidate read
duplicates but once you consolidate them
in this black beak you can see the
percentage of actual total leads that
are unique or can be quite low in an FFP
material so this could probably be about
ten percent of the leads are actually
unique and that's that's a huge
difference and it's incredibly important
in thinking about sensitivity in cancer
genotyping if you you don't really need
to see the detail list this is a slide
pile up using our custom viewer that
long has developed it's a pile up around
one gene I'm showing you just the plus
plus the plus reads up here the ministry
is down here let's ignore those you can
see this this pile up over this
particular gene I don't remember which
teen it is is very blocky so you have
many nucleotides here you probably have
20 nucleotides between here and here but
you have no leads that start or stop
there and so this is a very low
complexity sample and if you don't um if
you don't remove duplicates what do you
see well let's say we have in this pile
up 200 reads we have two variant calls
here that look real a red one and a
purple one the red one these are
probably about 10 to 20 reads in that
little clump here in 10 to 20 beads in
that clump and interestingly what if you
look out to the ends you can see these
clumps are actually all start and stop
at the exact same place so while we had
let's say 40 reads out of 200 showed
this mutation we actually know there are
only two mutant reads and it's a very
different that's very different
sensitivity and a very different level
of confidence in the clinical lab
knowing you only have two reads and here
in purple we likely also only have two
weeks even though probably twenty to
thirty percent of the total reads in
this call were mutant it really it
really is probably just one or two
original template molecule so when we
see stuff like this we get very
concerned and are very careful in our
interpretation of the data
so that's a general background into how
amp works and how how we utilized some
of the error correction and complexity
information what are we actually doing
we have a snapshot replacement panel we
call it NGS then snap shot NGS which is
also ant based we have a ballot actually
Sivan sorry I should've update is about
50 targets now many of the original
snapshot genes are there except we now
have full coverage of some of our tumor
suppressor genes like p53 smack for SDK
11 and so we have good coverage with all
of the advantages that we were talking
on and we have about a two percent to
five percent analytical sensitivity and
we think we can get things done quickly
reasonably the reasonable price with a
small amount of input material which is
incredibly important for for for a
clinical language which really deals
with many many very small samples we've
gone from sixty percent of our lung
adenocarcinoma set of detection all
drivers to over eighty-five percent of
them having detection level drivers some
of the other specific issues that I'm
going to talk about with snv's and in
dells are we do deduplication as looking
at the molecular indexing as well as
standard deviation phone by me mutek
variant calling for snv's long seem has
developed a custom in dell caller that
we use taking advantage of bidirectional
coverage assessment the analytical
sensitivity that we found in our
validation studies are less than five
percent across the board for for all of
our validation samples that we use we
had a lot of older snapshot samples that
we could use in and so the assay
performed quite well on genomic DNA just
to give you some some novel stuff if you
heard some of these stories before we've
we've actually begun to uncover although
this is not an ultra sensitive
technology there's an honest rly
something that you would use for
monitoring solid tumors and blood or
plasma it is quite sensitive so from any
we feel comfortable gun in the
one-percent range if we have enough
coverage and we've begun to find i would
say unexpected heterogeneity of common
drivers so i'm going to show you some
examples recent examples that we found
of andreas and idh1 mutations in
email and NPS which are really quite
interesting stories these are put
together by valentina nori a pathologist
in our group so I give her some credit
here i th wanted to is a very high
interest obviously to to some diagnostic
lab as well as to some of the
therapeutics clinical trial that
pharmaceutical companies what I'm
showing you here are five patients that
we've performed genotyping in in a
five-page with AML that we performed
genotyping in in gray or the last counts
so it's presumably the tumor burden and
then in blue and red are idh1 and idh2
mutations that we found in the same
patient that is within the same
patient's tumor I had always assumed and
I think it was a general assumption by
many maybe maybe not all people in the
field in the AML field that I th was an
initiating event we have some cases like
patient 3 we're clearly the blast count
is much much higher even if you add the
two i th one and two two components
together those two subpopulations
together so these these patients which
have both idh1 and two mutations really
support the idea that that there's an
initiating clone on which background
their selection for mutation in the ith
pathway so you may ask well are these
occurring in the in the same patient or
not this is a case where we actually
have two separate idh2 mutations in the
same patient and what you can see from
the lead pile up here is that the
mutations are actually in different or
in trance they're on different alleles
we've not been able to prove yet they're
in different cells but they certainly
aren't different learning different
alleles and so then interest as led us
to look at some other other genes and we
found actually in AML as well that
there's common heterogeneity in the NRS
gene obviously a known well-known common
driver and the mutations are in with the
hotspot codon 12 and 13 loci so this is
a case that we found recently that had
four
for non overlapping mutations I can show
you the read pile up down here I'm only
showing you a small portion there's
probably another couple of hundred read
supporting but you can see the main
mutation is there but there's also a
another mutation here another mutation
here and there's two here and
interestingly if you zoomed into it
which I don't have they're all mutually
exclusive so this is something we've
begun to seen in a number of cases and
this is the second case from a few
months ago also Valentina's case that
had three endress mutations this is a
patient with with myelodysplastic
syndrome and you can see one two three
separate and mass communications and all
mutually exclusive so we're quite a
we're quite excited although this is not
a discovery excellent platform we are
excited that it's it's very good
sensitivity is allowing us well when it
allows us to things it allows us 12 very
sensitive assay that works well on low
input material sample so we don't reject
that many samples in the clinical lab
and number two it's beginning to reveal
some heterogeneity which is exciting but
i would say probably more stressful than
exciting right now for the clinicians
who have to deal with this snv
applications i'm not going to talk about
the the general applications all of you
know about egfr testing bereft testing
i'm not going to go into those kind of
details which i assume everyone is well
aware of but some of the new
applications we're looking at that
almost excited about or inside logic
samples many of you probably know about
your indica for elves work in thyroid
from the University of Pittsburgh done
some great work I think following on
that we were excited to apply NGS we've
applied our solid tumor panel to several
cytologic samples including pancreatic
cysts which we this basically standard
of care of mgh that all pancreatic cyst
fluids get sent for NGS and this study
which is which is nearly completed with
Martha Pittman and are so tall cytology
division around bile ducts psychology
which can be very very difficult so in
this study
we use our NGS approach the DNA approach
to take cytological samples from bile
duct scrapings biopsies these bile ducts
are within the pancreatic head or or the
common bile duct or extra paddock the
extra panic bile ducts or the pancreatic
duct sorry and in this particular study
we looked at about 70 for patients 81
total cases we got material we extracted
the DNA and then we performed genotyping
on it as you can see of those patients
21 had que vas mutations interestingly
14 had p53 mutations and so what is that
what does all that mean well we had
clinical follow-up on them and we use
clinical follow-up as kind of the gold
standard for determining sensitivity and
specificity of these assays cytology as
any of you in pathology know is not
great ed bile duct from a sensitivity
standpoint for those patients who ended
up with a positive clinical follow-up
for neoplasia or malignancy cytology was
only sensitive for 67% fish which is
commonly used as an adjunct was
sensitive and fifty-five percent and NGS
and seventy-four percent so NGS at least
in our data set was what was was better
and when you compared when you added
psychology and NGS you've got a boost to
eighty-five percent sensitivity with a
very very good specificity so a study
that's that was a fair amount of work
but I think very exciting that showing
NGS can be really important not just in
predicting which drugs patient should go
on but can help pathologists make
diagnosis so in the diagnostic arena
similar to I think how URI has has
looked at some of his thyroid work
interestingly maybe not surprising to
some of you p53 mutation was correlating
not just with neoplasia but with
malignancy so 13 of these 14 p53
mutations at follow-up had a bona fide
diagnosis of malignancy and we don't
have a whole lot of markers molecular
markers that would allow you to say that
is not just a neoplasm like
can tell you it's a neoplasm it can tell
you this morning p53 mutation in this
setting is is quite strong predictor of
this is a malignancy in we ought to do
something aggressive so we're excited
about them CNVs we look at CNVs and
commonly every case that we run through
our genomic dnas a or solid tumor as it
gets cnv coverage it's a simple we do
the simply by looking at the weed
coverage this case we're looking at
several exons and introns fly base pairs
into the introns allows us to do read
counts at those positions obviously you
would not be getting RNA interference
for leads that extend into the intron so
almost all of our gsps are within exons
and if those read into introns we can
just read those and take the median of
those over particular genes and then
normalize that data and that gives us
our CMV coverage we've been happy happy
with it I'll spend a few minutes talking
about cien veces there's obviously a
huge amount of interest NGS along with
the array CGH and other pc are other
grind up and analyze assays as i call
them they're very good at detecting high
level amplification so this is a GBM
which a lot of people use because they
have so much EGFR in this cases in egfr
amplification that amp clearly picked up
very easily you see the recount is way
off the top of this law to scale and in
this case we actually confirmed by fish
we currently are confirming all of our
applicants by fish this case it confront
this case was interesting because it
actually had a focal in this case you
can see over here at focal pdgfr alpha
amplification here there's about three
or four cells there but it was still
picked up by Miami and then several
other genes for loss and that we're
normally an official confirmation of
them so we're happy of the performance
again why we excited about it most
platforms these days that have fairly
robust T and V detection low input
material low input ffb material seems to
be performing really well so for
somebody's over our cnv work what can I
tell what can I tell the audience I can
say we
for a mall potential amplification with
fish we don't have a hard cut off in
terms of the log two ratios that we use
in general or normalized log two ratios
of greater than 1.5 will go to fish
confirmation but our pathologists are
molecular pathology to actually make
those decisions and i can tell you our
group has definitely seen cases where
the log 2 ratio is less than 1 but
clearly above the background of the rest
and those confirm this bonafide
amplifications by fish those are
expensive especially problematic and low
input materials our confirmation rate
using fish is very high so we find
something suspicious by amp and we do
fish over ninety percent of those I'm
you say confirmed as bona fide
amplifications where we run into
problems because we're now looking at
really comprehensive whole genome
coverage is we run into Poly's only
chromosome 7 pounds only being the most
common for egfr i met probably the most
common confounder that that would in my
opinion should not lead to any treatment
implications so fish confirmation least
with the size panel we have now is
probably important for at least a subset
of low-level amplification cases true
bona fide low-level amplification and
for those of you who run clinical labs
and do her to fish I'm talking about
ratios near 2 point 0 in my opinion
remain an area for more rd that we've
not been able to tackle this and really
get or get our arms around it cnv
analysis when you grind and analyze is
obviously majorly affected by the amount
of contaminating normal stromal or
normal normal other cells that are
present and affect the denominator and
numerator of your ratio analysis so as
you get down to lower lower levels of
amplification which are clinically
meaningful ie her two ratios near two I
think we still have a lot more work to
do this is the last one is my personal
statement I think is a statement of fact
but I'll leave everyone out there to
make their own decision to me fish
remain superior and will likely always
remain the gold standard for copy number
but since it is so limited in its
ability to multi
and or other NGS techniques clearly have
advantages and cost and efficiency and
that's a compromise that I think we have
to make we may not be able to make that
for her to in breast but going forward I
think we will have to and should make
that for most other tumors let's move on
to rearrangements we have most of our
data and most of the excitement around
the use of amp and the archer technology
for detecting rearrangements there are
other ways to detect rearrangements
there's IHC will talk about the
expression levels of different different
rearrangements some jeans or great elk
is great you can you can use any news to
chemistry to detect out compactors
there's some some great approved essays
out there for for for alch detection elk
is not normally expressed in than one so
for our positive tumors iht use great
ross not-so-great moment will show you
some data for that they should I love
fish they have done tons of fish over
the years that was really important for
the development of croissant nib it's
it's a reliable good a say it is
technically challenging you d do need
in-house expertise pathologist in my
opinion especially and the ability
multiplexes is very limited rt-pcr is
great it works fantastic you can design
specific primers however you have to
know both partners and as we found out
and I'll show you in a few slides that's
really not practical going forward the
essay design for Rosslyn it really not
outlined how amp works in a multiplex
manner but it works very very well in a
multiplex manner you can pull GSP ones
into one tube so you can put over a
thousand if you'd like GSP ones into 12
in PCR one and then move that into the
next two which is pcr to with your GSP
2s and so you can multiplex the essay
over over a thousand excuse me
I'm talking too much so by map it by
doing the reeds and mapping them you can
map whether you're on the next X on
whether you map following this GSP one
or two direction into the next fusion
gene or into an intron so as I said we
use total nucleic acid so we will get
all types of reeds within any particular
assay in this particular case we're
looking for Ross fusion so we're really
looking to do five prime race in this
case so that's how the essay works why
do we care about fighting unknown
partners because there are so many
partners as you know for alch there's
probably 20 or more probably closer to
30 partners each of these five prime
partners can have multiple break points
rt-pcr becomes unwieldy and you really
are lacking clinical sensitivity
clinical sensitivity I'm going to skip
over this slide in the interest of time
make everyone's heard enough probably
about fish about the same time that we
started working on elk the roasterie
arrangements were described by the cell
signaling group here up in Boston also a
receptor kinase similar structural
structurally related to to alch in the
kinase family and as we found out later
also also primarily in young non-smokers
so we began to screen for ross patients
buy fish at the same time boss fish is a
little easier than out fish because the
genes generally are farther apart and
like out the route the response of
responsive patients took rosanna has
been phenomenal so probably know this
story quite well but one of the
important things to take home from all
this is the prevalence is low so many of
the things we're talking about a very
low prevalence loss is probably in the
one-percent range for long and to do 100
fish tests to find one ross positive
case is quite expensive quite tedious
and and challenging on the heels of alch
and Ross came read fusions obviously
Norman thyroid been described in lung
cancer than an Trk fusions been a real
chance paper on fgfr fusions across a
number of to no tumor types including
long and so I quickly became obvious to
us that we needed to move quickly into
the NGS space to look for multiple
targetable kinases with the flexibility
to look for novel fusions now we know
future partner fusion partners this is a
summary of our validation so we
developed a homebrew and pass a long as
only develop this looking at al cross
and red we also ended ntr k1 and PBR
gamma for some of our thyroid cancer
works so kind of a 15 right panel we
looked at amp the performance versus
fish where there's alcohol official red
fish and amp did extremely well on the
clinical what I'm called a clinical
validation we detected almost all the
positives and importantly in some of the
equivocal fish cases and I'll show you
one of those am presume it was able to
to solve some of our problems with with
unusual fish cases either calling it a
negative case for Al care or in this
case of Ross positive and in Los
negative one here and so those everybody
allowed us to resolve some some
challenging fish some challenging fish
findings so as they perform really well
head-to-head versus fish which we have a
lot of lot of data with and that leads
to a very important question around
analytical sensitivity I've had this
discussion with many many people here at
mgh within Archer and with with other
people in the fusion space how do you
determine analytical sensitivity it's
actually one slide does not do this
justice this is this could be a I'm
going to say it's supposing but at least
an hour long talk the problem is
standard serial dilution experiments are
very challenging and if you haven't
thought about this it's very easy to
explain RNA expression unlike DNA where
you generally have two copies in
normal tissue RNA expression can vary
widely so let's say you want to do an
alch set up an alch and gssa and you
want to know what is your analytical
sensing what's your limit of detection
okay so you pull now several normal lung
cancer cases or normal bone tissues and
you find your essays run quite sensitive
and why is that because all right
because elk is not expressed in normal
lung so every time you add more RNA or
cdna you're really not diluting out your
target I'm here to take Ross on the
other hand Ross is expressed in normal
long and it is expressed fairly highly
in about thirty percent of long too much
so now if your normal your quote normal
expresses the fair amount of Ross you're
going to get a very very different
analytical sensitivity so we were a
challenge for some time about how to
approach this issue of sensitivity and
there's no easy answer on the expression
vary significantly from normal sample to
normal sample from too many tumor and
it's not like DNA from even if you have
Poly's only within the tumor you might
have four coffees or eight copies you
can talk and several log difference of
expression here in that that's a real
challenge for a diagnostic lab to think
about another approach other than the
standard serial dilution i think i think
the serial dilution is worth doing in my
opinion to find a normal a standard
normal let's say or a small number of
normals that you would use and give a
distribution of a distribution of
sensitivities the other approach which
really would depend on having large
number of cases the set the second two
approaches depend on having a large
number of positive samples is you can
get a large number of a local ross or
red or NT okay whatever future in case
you're interested in and look for just
statistical distributions of those how
many reads do you get for those positive
cases if you had clinical follow-up
that'd be even better so that's
something we're looking into but you
really need probably over 100 cases to
be able to do that with any any proof
and the approach that we've taken has
been to establish a minimal tumor
percentage so we found in our I'm going
to go back a few slide we found in our
validation set you know you can see we
have over 100
clean these we probably have close to
100 positive cases and so you can
establish what is the lowest amount of
tumor percentage then you've identified
a true positive that correlated between
fish and NGS and our cutoff currently
stands around fifteen percent we think
we can go lower for a certain target
especially out we think they know
significantly lower but this also
depends on having large number of cases
so this is an area that I'm happy to
talk to anyone offline I think it's a
major challenge for the field it's not
an ant specific problem but it's a it's
a question that most I think most
regulatory agencies and really want to
know how are you going to approach so I
think we need to talk a little bit more
about that skip quickly through this
this was our first thousand cases using
this one thyroid panel about six percent
positive cases lots of red alcon raw
Ross as you would expect so about six
percent positivity rate on to the next
slide I'm going to skip over this in the
interest of time other than to say we
can detect novel complex rearrangements
this was a indeterminant ross fish case
as i said it is help us solve some cases
in this case we have a green only dot
which you don't really know what to do
with in some of these cases agree only
god is on the five prime end of the ross
gene in our assay and so in this case
the the positivity was a complet must
have been a complex rearrangement which
deleted the three prime probe was
confronted policies by amp even in the
past year or so there's been a lot
there's been a number of papers
including this paper from the blueprint
medicines group that is described even
more fusions novel fusions of kinases in
cancer so we've worked hard to continue
to keep up with the literature which is
not always easy within lung for instance
the number of fusions has gone from
al-quran rasta probably we have about 20
genes now that we're actively looking at
and need to keep track of this paper
came out of the forest Bassianus group
in 2014 just showing spits neva ml and
almost increasing number of fusions so
for this reason
we've now moved to a larger 50 gene
fusion assay which we're excited about
we've launched and now use routinely the
first 150 cases of this assay we were
very excited that we had a significantly
higher positivity rate almost ten
percent of our cases this was all tumor
types it's not it's not limited to long
or thyroid we found various fusions and
by fusions I include some RNA
rearrangements such as main exon 14
skipping in egfr 33 I have just a few
more slides I'll try and finish up a
little early so we can have questions
it's probably a lot of interest in the
audience on nexon 14 skipping do you
look at RNA or DNA we generally prefer
using the fusion based SI the cdna based
assay to look for RNA gives you very
easy read out of no x on 14 but if you
have DNA within the surrounding introns
you can find in this is a case that was
positive for exxon 14 is given by RNA
where we have actually DNA genomic reads
at the splice site of intron 14 and in a
summary of 11 positive men exxon 14
skipping patients we found almost all of
them well in fact all of them except for
one we didn't have an additional
material had DNA mutations that
correlated with the army mutations you
probably know some of this data from
other publications this was this was
limited barclay the lung cancer
adenocarcinoma and squamous cell
carcinoma patients and interestingly
almost all of them were never smokers so
along with alch red Ross another kind of
non smoke and egfr another non-smoking
lesion that's highly target of all so
obviously many people excited about Max
on 14 skipping for expression just in
the last few minutes you can look for
RNA expression in this TNA based assay
even if you're reading even if you're
reading through into an interim it's
actually you can use that data you can
use that data to help correct for for
DNA reads so in this case we have
basically rrna coverage equals the weed
within the exon minus a very close
intron coverage so by subtracting this
intronic coverage you basically are
subtracting almost all
of the DNA by genomic ting a breeze that
are coming through this area so that
allows us to profiling expression
profiling this is this is a summary of
our 50 gene fusion panel these jeans are
on the bottom if the genes themselves
are not really critical other than to
show you the data actually looks quite
good using this normalization procedure
that song Lee has come up with it's a
log scale over here on the y-axis and
each of the genes this is a summary of
200 different samples per gene so this
cloud is 200 different samples and you
can see a widely variant expression from
point 1 up to 100 so you can have three
logs or more of difference of expression
using amp base expression profiling in
this case this is alch right this is a
very low expresar as we would expect in
lung cancer you don't see much elk and
then you see some very high level
express errs such as beta 2
microglobulin and other housekeeping
genes here and here so that brings up
just in the last minute or two some very
important issues for expression you have
to balance primers it's really important
and the reason is you pay a lot of money
to sequence these highly expresses
unlike micro arrays where you might max
out a particular spot on an array you're
not going to pay more money for that
spot if you keep sequencing your
housekeeping genes you're going to keep
paying for sequencing and I'm sure
alumina or life loves it you're just
going to keep paying for sequencing so
you can balance the primers you can
bring down the primer concentrations as
you design your targeted expression
profiling essay to lower these level
that's in fact what we've done these are
normalized expression but the total the
raw read counts would be much lower than
what we're showing you here and we try
and normalize them also without the same
so that's really important is to balance
primers the essay we are excited about
and we think it's working well this is
one example a recent data set again 201
cancers where we have Alec expression
and Ross expression elk you can see up
here or matts only has mapped the AL
confusion positive cases which we know
no express a lot of alch versus the
cloud of negative cases so we
if we think we're really seeing true
expression profiling Ross on the other
hand is mapped the fusion positive Ross
cases and you can see those cases the
expression of Ross in a fusion positive
cases falls right in the middle of the
Ross cloud and just for your floor for
your edification you can see that it's
almost two logs difference median
expression of mount vs raw sears beta
beta 2 microglobulin is as a as a
comparison so that's a quick run-through
expression it's something that we're
actively working on though the archer
guys are working on so just to summarize
quickly amp technology for targeted
sequencing of RNA and DNA offers
advantages of both hybrid capture and
amplicon sequencing in one platform you
can do high confidence calls with
complexity information from low quality
leather coat archive samples the
workflow can be scaled up to over a
thousand primer sets per too so you can
you can you can you can do quite a bit
of work in a single panel i think and
i'm excited at least in our R&D group to
continue the development of novel
applications panels and basic amount
informatics and error correction tools
and then the last slide is just a thank
you this is a beautiful picture from
Boston no I'm sorry that's not Boston
but it's what I wish Boston look like as
we head into the fall and winter major
thanks go to long and some way from our
team who hopefully you can you could
everyone can you can everyone still hear
me ok just to thank long and suddenly
who really did all the lion's share of
work here I'd like to thank also from
the archer team Jason Steve and Josh
especially Jason who founded Archer
together with long and myself and it's
been an incredible partner we've we've
learned a lot not just about business
but about science so I've taken up all
of our time but I'm more than happy to
stay on for questions for though you can
stay on
great thanks John for that presentation
you have a lot of questions and due to
time will will answer just a handful of
them and address the remaining via email
so the first question how do i gauge how
do i best gauge the quality of my input
material should i you should i be using
a fixed nanogram amount or is there some
other recommended way you think Archer
is also adopted out front we have we've
adopted some upfront QC steps Archer
also has adopted a similar I don't think
identical but similar are on QC steps
which can save you a lot of effort
downstream for instance for cdna
assessment we have an upfront cdna
quality screen which correlates really
really well to library success and
sequencing success so having those I
think saves a lot it's a little bit of
work upfront it's a little bit of qpcr
upfront but really saves saves a lot of
time and effort I think will make you
and your text very happy
alright great thanks another question
for our date from ffpe what extraction
method do you recommend and are there
any special tips to ensure that you get
reliable data along with that what is
the average size of RNA molecules and
the five prime three prime bias effect
that you see I'm not sure I understood
this second i'm not sure i interested
the second part of the question
extraction of RNA you know we've tried
and we tried a number of approaches bead
base bright clean up based approaches as
well as kaijin type collet column
approaches it's really I don't like to
recommend I would leave that more to the
archer to your your Archer team to
comment on that we found that multiple
technologies work just fine for RNA
doing the upfront QC I think we'll let
you assess very quickly whether you're
getting high enough quality RNA with
that said I do think the major challenge
people have had to adapting amp
technology has been poor RNA quality in
their own laboratories from ffpe so it's
not that extraction is not the critical
step i think it is actually the most
important step because the technology
works i think fairly simply i'm happy to
talk offline about specific products but
I'd rather not recommend anything what
is the average side what is the average
doctor who
the second part of the question what is
the average size of RNA using it we are
sequencing uses 150 base pair paired
reads we we don't really dictate the FFP
material dictates the size of the rnase
i would say anywhere anywhere between
you know 100 and 300 base pairs
averaging 150 to 200 but that's not
really at our discretion it's more than
the condition of the the RNA but if you
have it you know you need you need
probably about a you know you need
somewhere in 100 to 200 base pairs to
get enough reads that you can get you
need to map both to your gene of
interest as well as a potential partner
so you probably need 20 base pairs on
both sides plus your primer sequencing
so there are there a minimal amount
minimal RNA length that is required for
the assay but it's generally not been a
challenge for us
great thanks for that answer John
another question how about DNA seek
based fusion detection instead of cdna
um good question as I said I didn't want
to have an exhaustive review of other
technologies I think there's many many
other technologies that that could have
been looked at for fusion detection the
problem with genomic DNA and I'm just
going to kind of make a make it a very
explicit answer hopefully not
oversimplifying it or insulting anyone
but most fusions are within introns and
some of those introns can be very very
long so to do fusion detection from
introns you pay a lot of money you have
to in many cases tile across large very
large introns and you pay for all of
that sequencing so for the same amount
of money that you could put maybe five
or ten probes to look at let's say the
AL kinase domain and the amount of
sequencing that it takes to read into
through that cdna you may need 50 or
more probes to tile probably more
hundreds to tile across those and you
pay for that sequencing and that can be
expensive
thanks John I'm glad that question was
asked next one what do you think about
dr. James wiley's approach to using
competitive template spike ins to
accurately quantify starting template
for the targeted RNA and DNA seek
applications I like the idea I think I I
think artificial templates artificial
spikings all of those are really really
valuable and I think are a good step I
didn't include that as a possible step
or approach to the analytical
sensitivity artificial templates I think
do have do have an important role I do
like to be very very explicit however
that we like to think as molecular
diagnostic of diagnosticians that we can
predict the sensitivity in every sample
that is in front of us and what I'm
trying to point out is the RNA
expression of any of your targets let's
say of at 50 gene panel those 50 genes
in the surrounding normal lung tissue
can be highly variable and so although
your spike ins can give you some
assessment of how the essay itself
performs it doesn't give you complete
confidence in every single sample that's
in front of you because of the biology
it's not it's not the technical
limitation it's the biological
limitation that we have to come to terms
with so we can we can figure out yeah
this essay performs as well as any other
essay out there on the market and you
can use spike ins to do that it doesn't
help me as a clinician saying in the
patient in front of me we have a five
percent sensitivity when we really don't
know because the RNAs are so widely
while widely expressed I hope that made
some sense
great thanks John so we just any in this
for the sake of time think we're going
to close and we will well we'll answer
the remaining questions on a one-on-one
basis of the email will follow up with
you today's webcast will be available
for for on-demand viewing on both on
labret skaam and on Archer DX calm and
will let you know when that's available
so you can you can you can revisit or
you can share with people who aren't
able to come thanks to dr. I afraid II
for taking the time to prepare and
present present your work John
appreciate it and also thank you all for
attending attending this webinar and
we'll see you next time have a good day